Préparez-vous à faire un voeu !
Cette nuit, si le ciel est clair,
vous aurez peut-être la chance
d'observer une ou plusieurs étoiles filantes.
En réalité, ces objets célestes
n'ont rien à voir avec les lointaines étoiles
qui scintillent au firmament.
Le phénomène se déroule à seulement 70
kilomètres au-dessus de nos têtes.
Chaque année, dans sa course autour du
soleil, la Terre traverse des zones
un peu plus poussiéreuses.
Ces poussières ont été laissées
par des comètes qui se déplacent dans la galaxie.
Vous savez, des boules de glace et de
poussières précédées ou suivies
par une chevelure et une queue.
Quand la Terre traverse l'une de ces régions,
les poussières pénètrent dans
l'atmosphère. Elles subissent
d'importants frottements et finissent
par entrer en combustion, générant ce que nous appelons une pluie d'étoiles filantes.
Et une capsule pour déconfiner.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleu, vous pouvez
également voir ou revoir celles des jours
précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J'en réalise une nouvelle par jour, mais
pour être sûr de n'en louper aucune,
eh bien abonnez-vous et activer la cloche.
Allez, à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés,
mais on reste en lien.